intérieur elle est très déterminée merci
monsieur ministre la parole est un
monsieur david douillet pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président j'ai associé
à ma question monsieur thierry solère et
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
avec monsieur thierry solère justement
nous sommes allés comme la plupart dans
tout ça c'est bon visiter une prison
la semaine dernière nous avons constaté
malheureusement plusieurs choses d'abord
que tout circule dans les prisons et
couteaux la drogue des téléphones
portables avec complète des complicités
extérieures bien sûr ces mêmes téléphone
portable qu'on peut retrouver jusque
dans les quartiers d'isolement
là où sont incarcérés les radicaliser où
les terroristes
un pléonasme ma première question elle
est toute simple c'est une solution
pourrait être de mettre des brouilleurs
dans ces cellules d'isolement pour qu'un
minime à ces détenus ne puisse pas
communiquer il m'a dit imaginez vous ce
qu'un téléphone portable peut faire
comme dégâts entre les mains de
quelqu'un de radicaliser deuxième chose
nous avons constaté que les directeurs
de prisons ont pas accès lorsqu'ils
reçoivent un détenu aux fiches s en
particulier de personnes radicaliser
c'est à dire qu'un détenu condamné pour
des délits de droit commun classique le
directeur n'est pas au courant qui peut
être radicaliser ou pas la période
allait en général d'un mois pour
découvrir que le personnage est
radicalisée vous imaginez le
prosélytisme qu'il peut faire au sein
d'une prison au contact des autres
détenus avant d'être mis à l'isolément
monsieur le premier ministre il est
temps d'agir vite rapidement de se
mettre l'action les français attendent
ça pour plus d'efficacité
merci monsieur douillet
la parole est à madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice président mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député david
douillet je me réjouis que vous soyez
rendu dans un établissement
pénitentiaire et j'invite une fois de
plus cela fait plus de deux ans je le
fais tous les parlementaires à s'y
rendre
vous savez bien entendu que la
radicalisation violente n'est
malheureusement pas confinée dans nos
prisons et c'est bien la complexité de
la situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
néanmoins nous prenons très au sérieux
la radicalisation qui peut survenir dans
nos prisons nous le faisons avec ce
régime d'isolement qui est infligé aux
détenus les plus radicalisées un
isolement qui est complété par des
contrôles fréquents et des
transfèrements d'établissement un autre
aussi souvent que nécessaire
le régime de surveillance pour les
détenus radicaliser ou en cours de
radicalisation vous savez que nous avons
conforté très substantiellement leur
enseignement pénitencier à qui était
composé de 70 agents et qui est
aujourd'hui composé de cent cinquante
neuf policiers et l'année prochaine 285
nous avons déployé une quarantaine
d'officiers dans les établissements
pénitentiaires concernant les
brouilleurs nous avons 628 brouilleurs
en service donc 95 établissements
ces brouilleurs pose pourtant un certain
nombre de contraintes très lourdes qui
sont liées à l' architecture qui peut
perturber par exemple émissions des
signaux qui sont liés à des technologies
qui évoluent très vite mais qui sont
liées aussi à des problématiques de
santé et sur les personnels sur les
détenus et sur les voisins selon la
puissance d'émission de ces brouilleurs
néanmoins nous avons conduit en 2015 une
expérimentation sur des brouilleurs de
très haute technologie et ses bouilleurs
de dernière génération seront déployés
dès janvier 2016
nous avons des détecteurs de téléphones
portables nous en avons 289 il y en aura
3 146 d'ici à la fin d'année ce qui
couvrira 80 % de nos établissements
par ailleurs nous avons recruté 140
agents spécifiquement pour effectuer des
fouilles sectorielle qui sont plus
fréquentes et plus légère voilà monsieur
le
et l'essentiel des solutions
technologiques